I borrowed that phrase from you by the
way so like the netflix moment for music
what what does that mean to you so with
what that means is as you've seen by the
remarkable success of Netflix we've
reached a point where a lot of people
know about Netflix and they understand
the idea and the value of Netflix and
and people have embraced that I'm all
around the world right and so in Vega
traditional it's like a part of their
viewing yes right yeah everyone who has
broadband and has a TV at home will will
have netflix at amazon prime and that
same thing hasn't happened in music in
music in essence the the value
proposition is better you get access to
more music more content as a percentage
of total music than you do on netflix
and you can download it unlike what you
can do on netflix but the the main part
of the population for the most part
around the world doesn't really end but
isn't it because there's confusion as to
what exactly you can get right yes
Anthony on each on each service also
jay-z coming out with his own music
streaming service and saying I'm gonna
put exclusive content on this one so you
come to mind you don't even like there's
there's confusion there on that part I
think I think as you said the biggest
issue really is confusion it's its first
of all understanding the idea if you
went to people and said you can have all
the songs that are on iTunes for one
flat fee a month and you can download
and take them with you you can make
playlists or stations and and and you
told people that was available most
people would be surprised right and they
said I don't tie me up yeah well sign me
up and so that's really the value
proposition of streaming music whether
it's from our do or from another service
eventually from apple and and the
biggest challenge we have at the moment
is most people don't understand that
yeah there's there's a certain amount of
difference with exclusives it's not
clear how that will work out I think for
the most part the idea of exclusives is
not good for fans when you think about
it well the idea that people will
subscribe to multiple music services in
order to get just a few songs or a few
artists I think is going to slow down
the whole category it's it's hard enough
right now to get people to want to pay
and understand the value of ten dollars
a month right the idea that they would
subscribe okay well every song but those
three artists is on this service and
then I like those three artists I have
to
grab the two of them just for that it's
easier just to buy me so how do you get
over that hump because some of this is
controlled by the artists themselves
right somes controlled by the artist
more is controlled by the the labels
label yeah and for the most part
although I think there's been a lot of
press around what else what jay-z yeah
yeah yeah so Taylor Swift is on our do
you know Taylor Swift's issue was not
picking a streaming service Taylor's
issue and I was here a few months ago
and talked about that night that issue
was the idea of free on-demand music so
the bigger issue really is not so much
at the moment whether there's exclusives
or not but it's whether or not people
should be able to get anything they want
that we're gonna get rid of the free
music tier yeah we we we have a
different free music tier so our
approach to this was different than
Spotify or YouTube when we think it's
much more friendly to but we are so
what's different about yours ours is
much more like a Pandora so it's radio
the biggest difference between a pandora
style service or our radio service and
something like YouTube or Spotify free
is you pick a station I could make a
Taylor Swift station but we program the
music on that station so if you go to
Pandora you make a station they pick the
songs so that's really a new form of
radio and radio in the idea of radio is
you're picking a station you don't pick
a song so right it doesn't take away
from sales and and that's the biggest
difference whereas if i could say i want
to listen to this song right now why
would I ever buy that so what's what's
the proposition Anthony then what's the
proposition to say I'm gonna pick our do
today like what do i do you get that
list their visa V radio sirius Spotify
Pandora what's the definition it's a
great question so you know in the end
you you end up I used to work at amazon
and so I think Jeff Bezos says it best
you have to start with a customer and
work backwards you have to focus on
delivering the best customer experience
both in the terms of the design of the
product in the in the content and
available that you make available and
then where you can listen so that is
that is what then so we tend to win
pretty much hands down on product design
you know we started as a design first
company a lot of our designers are from
Apple so we win awards almost all the
time for for that I think inside the
product designers all right Anthony
great
see you ain't so much acid ebay rdio CEO